[Music]
all right he had to go get his hat get
my hat off
i don't want this hat
i want my other hat well what what other
hat my other [ __ ] hat my other
baseball hat your other [ __ ] hat i
had my tactical hat i got your she's not
crazy go ahead
you see what he does like last minute
uh as you can probably tell it's sunday
so he's been at the bar most of the day
already and we decided even though now
last night was saturday night we didn't
drink last night we actually stayed in
and watched a ken russell movie which
we're talking about today
uh i didn't have any drinks last night
so we decided that we were just gonna
have one now well you've already had a
bunch but this is my first one this is
my condor this one this one's more
comfortable
yeah a comfortable hat you're
comfortable hey you got your comfortable
hat and your [ __ ] second hand yeah
that's it this is formal
that's very formal you never know some
[ __ ] might show up or something you
don't know
they've been just disembodied cops yeah
yeah i don't know
you never know might have making this
[ __ ] up dj maniac is very excited that
we were talking about the devils um i
was actually i'm glad you told me that
it was because i had just looked at
shutter like the day before you said
that and it wasn't on there so they must
have just added it that day they
actually shutter added like a [ __ ] ton
of like classics that was a good movie
serpent in the rainbow the fog halloween
two halloween three we're gonna be on
session nine well we've mostly we've
done most of them yeah we're gonna be on
them again though cause some of them i
wanna see again but um i wanna see
halloween three again yes they they
added halloween too as well yeah and uh
so yeah so they added a whole bunch of
like kind of like really classic movies
and the devils uh is one of them now you
had never seen it before i saw it a long
time ago it was probably at least 20
years ago i kind of remembered a little
bit about it now we'll get into i kind
of want to get into like the whole
censorship issue because if you've never
seen the devils uh it came out in 1971
uh ken russell directed it
probably
one of the most controversial films ever
made i mean it's not as
overtly so you know something like
caligula or something like that but it's
in like the same
uh kind of
area i'd actually put this in with
excalibur
you think yeah imagine if excalibur was
going on and it's
it's based in something that really
happened evidently in france and there's
a bunch of nuns and a bunch of religious
[ __ ] persecution kind of like kind of
like the uh the religious wars of the
1600s but it's excalibur yeah not as
operatic you know what i mean but it's
it's like that it's the same epic
kind of storytelling it's just the
setting's very different very different
yeah
the the main
the main motif
of this movie is how sexy
[Laughter]
oliver reed is the how
women cannot resist this [ __ ]
it's that mustache
i think that might be what it is he's
knocking him down of all ages and
getting robbed and he just keeps
twirling it twirl it yeah well this is
almost women all these nuns love this
dude everybody does everybody he is
getting so much tail in this movie and
he's a priest yeah and he's like
unapologetic he's like yeah that [ __ ]
happens you know yeah yeah and he
[ __ ] tries to talk his way out of it
you've impregnated my daughter and he's
like well
oh well
[ __ ] happens yeah [ __ ]
and then he's all patriotic and
nationalistic and even stands up
stands up to the [ __ ] french king
and protects the city
while the other cities fortifications
are getting torn down
and he's like you know don't give up
your defenses the king will take over
and you'll lose all your freedoms he's
trying to be an emperor
so basically they're talking about
states rights because it was city states
back then and that was mostly richelieu
that was behind that cardinal ritual
yeah it was a cardinal who was [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] to that he was uh kind of a
[ __ ] there's a lot of good scenes in
this it's a trip because this is mostly
based on a true story yeah i don't know
if a lot of people know
it's exaggerated obviously for uh film
but
a lot of the [ __ ] did really happen
exorcisms witch hunts
torture
crazy [ __ ] medical stuff the black
plague
it's all in here
that's why i was gonna say
to me it's kind of like excalibur
where it's like a tale that happened a
long time ago back in the honky
motherland
that you should know you should learn
from it that's what kind of movie it is
well like it's crazy i compared it to
caligula in the sense that it stirred up
the same entrepreneur or you know sallow
you know 120 days of sodom it kind of
like stirred up the same kind of
controversy even though i will say
the version that's on shutter
is not the entire uncut version in fact
it is actually really really difficult
to see the entire uncut director's cut
version
because i mean this the history of the
censorship of this movie is like really
really complicated now they did actually
manage to show back in 2002 in london
uh the british film critic mark kermode
he actually uh who is you know a big ken
russell fan and he's like a very
passionate advocate of film and very
passionately anti-censorship in film so
he was actually kind of found some of
the the cut scenes uh the most
controversial scenes and they were able
to like cobble the whole thing back
together and he had made a documentary
about the movie called hell on earth and
they showed that in london
but for whatever reason warner brothers
who owns this movie
have been reluctant to release an
uncensored version uh you know it did
release versions of it so this isn't the
unsensitive version that we know
but it's not too hard to find
the two scenes that are that were cut
out entirely uh there were little things
that were trimmed
such as uh in the us release the uk
release is actually a little bit longer
um because they didn't take out as much
the us release uh they were like we
don't want to see anybody's pubic hair
so any kind of like nudity and stuff
there were no there was no uh you know
bush or anything
and they uh cut some of the scenes
that uh where uh grandier oliver reed's
character was being tortured like toward
the end like with the thing going
through his tongue and him them like
breaking his legs and stuff um those
were originally longer
but they cut those scenes out now the
two scenes that were cut out entirely
but as far as i could i'm aware because
i've seen them
somebody uploaded them to dailymotion i
think so you can see them on there
they're not super long
uh there's one scene at the very end
when they bring uh after him spoiler
alert after grandier is burned at the
stake
and they bring his femur like his
partial femur to uh sister jean in the
in the you know none whatever thing what
do they call that convict
i couldn't remember
i couldn't remember that word for the
life of me when they bring her that um
she kisses it and then starts uh
masturbating with it yeah
yeah which yeah that that tracks uh so
that was like toward the end but the
most controversial scene two and a half
minutes long you know the scene where
they kind of have like all the nuns and
they're running around naked it's kind
of like an orgy situation
okay in the uncut version that goes on a
lot longer and all the nuns actually
pull down a big huge
um like statue of christ like on the
cross and start raping it okay yeah
essentially uh so that was deemed beyond
the pale
and so that whole two and a half minute
sequence was taken out like i said you
can still find it around
um i've seen i saw the bone masturbation
one on youtube actually but i think the
other one is on dailymotion
but so they're still in there but i
think that the
with all the stuff restored i think this
movie is supposed to be like 117 minutes
the one that's on shutter i think is 109
minutes or 110 minutes so it has like
several things cut out but it's still
like really good and worth watching now
juan says that excalibur is more more
epic it is
excalibur is actually a story that's
mythological so so it has to be
mythological grandiose this is
historical so it's a little bit more
realistic but it also goes over the top
too
the difference is is that
with this one
they're talking about real people and
they're talking about how
about how human nature is about how you
can manipulate
a mass of people and create mass
hysteria for political gain
which they do this in here in order to
[ __ ] stop
a nationalistic rebellion
because they're
they basically they show how
how a exorcist
being pressured by the king and the
kings they actually pressured by the
king's men can get a bunch of nuns to
turn on somebody and claim they're being
possessed by them but it also gives them
license to act like total hoes which
they enjoy because they've been locked
up in a damn nun nunnery they couldn't
get married because they were too ugly
nobody wanted them
so they were they would feel special and
they were getting it all with each other
now they weren't being punished for it
yeah they could do whatever they want so
it's a similar kind of
movie it's about european history the
history of the european mind
and how really not a lot of [ __ ] has
changed everything that they show in
this movie still applies in the modern
age they do it all the time it's just
that
it takes different forms now
well i kind of feel like doing this the
twin themes of this movie being
um you know what horrible things can
happen when all of the sexual repression
is sort of the order of the day and also
the way faith can be perverted uh to get
political gains like uh and how
outrage and hysteria stuff can be fueled
uh toward a particular end and how a
leader like a king could be manipulated
by a subordinates because the king
himself was just kind of an idiot really
and um
he was into all this kind of weird
gender bending type stuff but he was
he was like multi-dimensional sexuality
he had all different kind of and he he
was supposed to be a bastion of kind of
morality that would show up
in disguise to these weird [ __ ]
possession orgies
and [ __ ] call [ __ ] on it but he
didn't carry that was funny you know
just it's just it's yeah and it's really
good that's honestly one of the best
scenes it's the third the 13th by the
way is uh who that came in the 13th yeah
yeah um yeah at one point like he comes
because obviously like the whole orgy
situation has become very famous like
throughout france so he decides he's
gonna like you know get his retinue and
he's gonna uh
say he's duke someone or other yeah and
he shows up at the [ __ ] and he knows
that it's all [ __ ] yeah he does he
plays a trick on them it's like oh i
brought the blood of jesus christ and
it'll make all the demons go away yeah
and they hold it up to all the nuns and
they're like oh we're cured and then
he's like psych there's nothing in there
and then he's just like bye
everybody they take him out
just keep on going
that was like so it was like a hilarious
scene but it was also like kind of
horrifying yeah because you knew that
like the people in power absolutely knew
that this was [ __ ] they knew it was
all but they just let it continue anyway
even those people's lives were at stake
it was in their favor yeah because it
was helping them take it yeah he didn't
give a [ __ ] toppled the city states they
didn't care
it was it was in their favor but just
goes to show that
it's just there's a lot of truisms in it
and then
like the guy all over reed is playing i
forgot his name on a magnet no grande
grandier yeah
urban grand prix who was a real guy who
was actually burned at the stake back
right back in the 1630s he was a
lecherous [ __ ] totally
unscrupulous around these women i mean
he was definitely using his power to get
[ __ ]
and he shouldn't have been doing that at
all and then when they got pregnant he's
like oh well bye it's on you you take
care of it you know yeah
but
he wasn't totally bad he did have good
ideals and he was standing up for his
city of state he was very patriotic and
they were trying to get him to confess
to [ __ ] that he didn't do and he's like
[ __ ] you i'm not confessing this [ __ ]
you're going to have to burn me alive
you have to do all this [ __ ] and i'm
going to see my tears and [ __ ] i'm still
not giving it to you so i i you got to
respect him for that he kind of died a
hero and actually the real person did
too yeah now the thing about it well
that's what's so fascinating about
oliver reed's character and the real guy
because you know it's based on a real
guy and a lot of the stuff that they
show in the movie did actually happen um
is that oliver reads character grandier
he's not a good guy like you said he's
kind of abusing his power also yeah he
knows that everyone thinks he's the most
attractive [ __ ] on earth and he
is absolutely taking advantage they cast
that [ __ ] perfectly they cast that
oliver [ __ ] reed hell yeah that's the
sexiest [ __ ] ever to live he's
pretty foxy in this movie i gotta say
well they they didn't have access to
burt reynolds
burt reynolds absolutely would not have
worked in this
he's too burt reynolds is one of those
people that's like too modern you know
what i mean you know how we say like
some actors like you can't really see
them like they're good actors but if you
put them in like a period piece it's
weird yeah um i feel like burt reynolds
is one of those oliver reed could
absolutely play period pieces like all
day long
he is outstanding in this this is
probably his best role he's just this
okay oliver reed always kind of [ __ ]
kind of it reminded me once i got a
little bit older and was able to [ __ ]
realize what everybody looked like and
[ __ ]
oliver reed was kind of like kind of a
beefier version of bruce dickinson from
iron maiden if you look at the two they
look a lot alike bruce's a smaller you
know
but so yeah okay i can understand it he
was this uh beefy
[ __ ]
dude that did have some rock star appeal
to to him yeah there's something like
there's something there's some like sexy
indefinable
quality he has like this intensity yeah
i think it's his eyes actually i can
understand why women were attracted to
him he's not he's he's not an ugly guy
he's just not what in the united states
you would think of a sex symbol you
would think of a skinny dude or
something you know
and he's not fat but like you said he's
beefy yeah he's this beefy dude
and my personal impression of him as a
kid was that he was scary as [ __ ] i mean
just his voice i could scare me he is
kind of scary that was like like i said
he's very intense from burnt offerings
and and movies like that
he's got kind of like he's got a little
bit of lunatic going on behind the eyes
there you know he always
he always uh [ __ ]
gave me the impression as a kid is that
he was just a couple drinks away from
beating your ass which was probably
which was probably true because they say
that [ __ ] drank like a fish and
get arrested here you're walking down
the street naked here and
it was [ __ ] new york or san francisco
remember
the cops didn't do anything to him they
just
yes
i'll ever read you know
that [ __ ] happens sometimes
well in a way it's like it's funny that
he's kind of nervous i mean it's not
funny these little probably kind of
alcoholic you know yeah but um but i
kind of feel like he's maybe more known
for that than actually because he was
actually a [ __ ] amazing actor
and as i said
i think this is probably my favorite
role of his i mean just the impassioned
speeches he gives like that whole thing
at the end like before they're gonna
kill him like when he's trying to defend
himself at the trial and stuff like that
just [ __ ] great just like the way he
comes across he likes he's fantastic i
never saw the i never saw the movie
where he had the [ __ ] naked wrestling
scene with the other women in love that
was that was the one that ken russell
made before this one before this one
yeah
that would probably scare me
if i saw that
that's a good movie actually i'd be
scared by them oh also women in love
which was made before this yeah that had
glenda jackson in it and she was
originally supposed to be in this
in the vanessa redgrave role of the
hunchbacked nun
um but they asked her to be in it and
she was like man i've played enough kind
of like sex starved neurotic women no
thanks uh so she didn't want to do it
because i guess she'd played a few parts
like that prior and so they got vanessa
redgrave and ken russell said vanessa
redgrave was like super awesome and she
was like she would just do anything she
just threw herself into this [ __ ] yeah
um because the role that she plays is
very
very
over the top very outrageous straw dog
says this damn this movie looks insane
and need to watch it they're going yeah
yeah you need to see it it's good it's
good really yeah it's okay so it's based
on like i said it's based on a real
thing yeah
ken russell had made women in love with
united artists and it was like pretty
successful so united artists this is
like this is crazy united artist says to
him hey that aldous huxley novel the
devils of uh lou denna which is you know
was
a novel a non-fiction novel about the
actual event
and they were like why don't you make a
movie of that there had been a play of
it also by a guy named john whiting
about the same uh situation the same
event
so ken russell like read the book and
he's like holy [ __ ] that's fantastic i
want to make this movie
so he writes a screenplay and then he
gives it to united artists and they said
absolutely not we're not making that
movie
um even though they were the ones that
had suggested in the first place but
then warner brothers said that they
would do it
and warner brothers uh you know they
did it they you know uh put it out and
everything but
they were still like pretty once it was
made they were like yeah you need to cut
this out and that and the other thing so
that was like not that great either but
at least it [ __ ] got made yeah um
so let's talk about okay
let me say something what they're
interested in the stories about
organized religion i'm gonna say only
partially
more about history and the [ __ ]
government abuse
you have to understand that the catholic
church was not a religion at
in this
at this point in his at this point in
history it was a government system it
was a parallel government
it only had a religious facade over it
most of the people that were running it
didn't believe in that [ __ ] at all if
you wanted power and money you got into
that system well it was a useful fiction
useful [ __ ] fiction is what it was
and most people had the intelligence to
know exactly what it was it was more
like a government it was more like a
federal government
that was kind of lording over a bunch of
um
a bunch of monarchies so it was kind of
like europe's federal government more
than anything else
um
so it's not really so much about
religion
now it turns out the oliver reed type
character
there's a bunch of stuffs going on with
the protestants the people that are
protesting that [ __ ] system trying to
bring it to a religion
you find out basically that this oliver
reed guy who is a catholic priest is
also secretly kind of like a protestant
he hasn't proclaimed himself a
protestant but he does [ __ ] that a
protestant would do like he gets married
yeah yeah and in real life i don't think
that they brought this up in the film
but in real life uh not only did he
write a treatise like um arguing for
which they actually do bring up in the
film arguing for priests uh you know
should be allowed to get married yeah um
they shouldn't be celibate so he was
like a big advocate of that the real guy
was you i agree um well yeah i do too i
totally agree but yeah he was a big
advocate of that but and i don't think
they brought this up in the film and
maybe they should have but he'd also
written a satirical thing about cardinal
richelieu okay which obviously uh didn't
get him on anyone's game right right so
you know what i mean but yeah i don't
think they brought that up in the film
but uh the real life guy did actually do
that so
i wouldn't the priest to marry would
have [ __ ]
solved a lot of problems in the catholic
system
uh you want guys in there
who are normal
who could have a normal family life you
don't want guys you don't want celibates
in there
it has ramifications now
that's why that's why the cat the
protestant churches that basically took
over america
are that's why they're just so different
than the catholic church they're never
they
they never [ __ ] really yearn for
for
government power they already had their
own little powers and a bunch of little
cults basically but there's nothing
wrong with that nothing wrong with
little cults just be little religions
you don't want centralized decentralize
that [ __ ]
whenever anything becomes centralized it
becomes kind of
crimified scammified
even more so too much power too much
power behind one throne too dangerous
slasher fred says there's an 80s horror
movie called gothic which sort of tells
how which is also ken russell uh tells
how mary shelley was inspired to write
frankenstein i think i reviewed that
movie actually because i've seen that
multiple times uh they made another
movie about that it wasn't ken russell
obviously i can't remember who made it
but it was called haunted summer and uh
it wasn't quite as good i think julian
sands was in it i want to say i can't
remember who else was in it um or was
julian sands and gothic now i can't
remember but yeah there were two of them
you're asking how they can see the uncut
version i don't know okay so
the american version is okay and like i
said there's a billion different
versions of this so it's really hard the
version that's on shutter in the us
right now i think
is 109 minutes
now in the uk they just put out what
they called like a blu-ray what they
called a director's cut but i think that
one's maybe only 112 minutes and i don't
think it has the rape of christ scene
and the charred bone masturbation scene
put back in
so what you might have to do is get the
british version of the film and then
somehow find the two scenes like i said
i think somebody uploaded them on
dailymotion
um and maybe like insert them back in
yourself um like i said mark kermode
since 2002 has been advocating for
somebody criterion or whoever to release
an absolutely uncut version of the film
but so far there have been no takers
nobody wants to put those two scenes
back in there because they're apparently
still too controversial even in 2022 for
a bunch of latin names in there talking
about how the catholic church is for too
[ __ ] [ __ ] up they don't follow the
bible this and that my first wife was a
catholic
um
and i gotta hand the catholics uh i
gotta give credit where the credit is
due
they have the best churches
the best motif
okay yeah that's just topic as [ __ ] the
best sound of it the songs the sound the
look of the inside
their style all the [ __ ] the the
stained glass
um just all the damn
especially in the central and south
american churches just how beautiful
the the motif the decorative motifs are
they got that all right
but yeah some of the things about the
catholic church man they're just
kind of ruin it let the priest marry
that will [ __ ] that would solve a lot
of the church's problems well like i
said then you get like all these
sexually repressed awareness you do not
want weirdos in the damn church you want
real men in the church and of course you
have real women in the church too you
don't want
celibates not anymore that's an old
timey thing and you want normal people
in the church that could help normal
people and understand normal people
problems
and just this
changing those marriage laws in the
church would [ __ ] help the catholic
church a lot i think their numbers would
grow
because i feel like didn't they have for
a long time they had priests and stuff
like that who were ostensibly celibate
yes and they were giving uh like marital
advice to their congregations i'm like
how the [ __ ] would you [ __ ] know what
they're talking about now somebody
mentions in here that's that certain
priests were able to marry up until the
12th century they should have kept that
kind of stuff i think they should you
want normal people in the church that
have families and have wives or husbands
and let people marry
they can't help you if they're celibate
they don't know enough
the whole idea of well we have to
cloister these people to keep them clean
so they don't know anything about the
outside world that's not and then have
them giving life advice to people yeah
i'm like that's not what you want that's
not how that's going to work no that's
the opposite yeah
that came from the dark ages when the
outside world was [ __ ] up yeah you
know dom the bomb says tom in england
when we became protestant the monarch
became the supreme head of the church
taking the place of the pope yeah that's
right yeah the church of england yeah
yeah that made total sense though that
way england had its own church so it had
its own
control over what was being said inside
those damn churches i i would have done
the same
why let rome do it i i totally
understand why i would do that now
america basically did that our
protestant churches
basically were all local and localized
with local people and local families
doing it the closest thing we had to a
catholic church here in the united
states
that was american would have been the
mormon church the church of mormon which
um they're kind of cool if you ask me uh
i've studied what it is and they have it
it's almost kind of like uh
now the way
that religion started
come on now you know it's a lot like the
way scientology started hey i found
these gold plates in the woods but oh
you want to see them no um i don't know
where they are but
no one's allowed to look at him you'll
die or something but sure the church of
latter-day saints uh in its orthodox
form um
is a fine church
they got good music
good outfits they have hey we you join
us we'll you know our god will make you
a god if you're good and you can have
your own universe i mean it's that's
like leveling up my own planet yeah you
have your own planet
you know so
it's a wild-ass book
it's a wild book the book of mormon is
[ __ ] wild all right uh
they do rituals that are kind of like
something you see on the back of the
dollar bill it's very uh
what do you call it uh gnostic
but religions are what they are
everybody's
holy scripture sounds ridiculous to
other people who who are reading other
holy scriptures or like me too they all
sound they all sound ridiculous to each
other they're all traditions you know so
so you know i would say um
yeah that's all i want to say about it
[ __ ] um
it's all a point of view but man at
least let your [ __ ] priest marry it
solves so many problems
juan says there was a good bootleg with
the uncut film and the hell on earth
documentary floating around i got a copy
oh i have to look for that because i
wanted to see that i watched like um
some marker mode like interviews about
it and um he wrote like a big long like
i said he wrote a big long post where he
was trying to get them to release the
uncut version like criterion or warner
brothers or whoever but uh so far they
haven't done that
so let's talk about what actually
happens yeah in this in the movie right
uh you know after 30 minutes yeah after
30 minutes
everybody's
yeah yeah now as i said this is based on
a true story some of the stuff obviously
is exaggerated but um i went and read
about the actual guy uh grandier and
it's not really that exaggerated
so this takes place in i think the year
it's 1632
1632 1634 somewhere around there yeah um
so yeah so we have louis the 13th he's
in power and uh cardinal richelieu who
is kind of like
you know in his ear all the time like
trying to get more power right
now at this time in france there were
these smaller cities that had
fortifications
so they're kind of like the the monarchy
in the church they're trying to get rid
of that they don't really like these
little cities having their own little
you know rules or little fiefdoms or
whatever
um and also they don't want like them
hiding out like a bunch of protestants
like i said this is the catholics trying
to breed out the protestants
so uh basically they've gone around and
torn down all the fortifications of
these other small towns but the town of
ludem they're basically like well
i made a deal with the governor of that
town like to leave them alone so we
can't do anything to them now the
governor dies of the plague though
so oliver reed is put in charge of the
town at least until they could there can
be another election so but then like the
kings guys are cardinal rituals guys i
think that's like a baron the guy that
comes and he starts tearing the walls
down and oliver reid's like what the
[ __ ] are you doing um i'm in charge and
you can't do this and i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill your ass if you keep doing it and
he's like well okay but
so behind the scenes
they kind of start to think well maybe
we need to like drum up some [ __ ] about
this grandier fellow so we can get him
out of the way and tear these [ __ ]
walls down
now uh grandier have to say not super
help in his case he's not a bad guy but
uh even though he's a priest like i said
he's a huge poonhound
and um he abuses his power somewhat but
see that was what i was saying before
about how i think this is like a really
good um kind of treatise on abusive
power because he's abusing his power in
like little ways
but then like the power of the combined
church and state comes down it's like
let me show you some real abusive power
[ __ ] and uh you know then he
just gets swept up in it and so you end
up like sympathizing with him even
though you know he has flaws uh but he
gets put into this situation that he
absolutely does not deserve because he
didn't kill anybody or anything like
that he's just like a poon hound he gets
a girl pregnant who was like the
daughter of a magistrate and you know
abandons her yeah he admits to all this
later yeah and he and he's not like he's
not sneaky about it either he's just
kind of like you can't hide it that's
what i mean well he he believed even
though he was a catholic priest he
believed that priests should marry like
i said and that's just like the real guy
and he was not um
i don't know he he just wasn't real like
up on this whole like celibacy thing and
he wasn't like really afraid to talk
about it now a lot of the nuns in the
town a lot of the women in the town in
general just cannot get enough of
grandier they love this dude they are
just like everybody's like they have all
this stuff like talking but i'm like oh
here he comes ooh you know what i mean
the nuns are the little nuns are peeking
over the [ __ ] thing to see him to
look at him
in themselves
here he comes here he comes here yeah
he's like a superstar yeah and it's
[ __ ] kind of hilarious when you when
you see it's oliver reed walking he's
like doing his mustache
like i said he's got that great he looks
good in this i think he's fantasizing
that he's jesus walking across the water
coming at him in his robe and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] in there and acting all this
[ __ ]
stuff out of the out of the [ __ ] new
testament and everything it's just if
you know if you understand new testament
mythology then you'll [ __ ] you'll
understand everything that's going on in
the movie yeah pretty much washing his
feet with her hair and
that's how these nuns are fantasizing
about how they're gonna get it on with
this father here yeah so it's not just
you know the the head of the mother
superior like at the uh
or whatever it's all the women are just
totally all
all about it yeah um and he's like i
said he's kind of like yeah that's right
you know i'm the man yeah
so
uh what he does so he secretly marries
he meets that woman that he marries her
name's madeline right he meets her when
he comes to her house before her mom is
dying at the plague and he comes there
and like gives her the last rights or
whatever and then apparently he falls in
love with her they secretly get married
which like i said is almost as
sacrilegious as like all the [ __ ] you
know
all the poon hounding he was doing yeah
um because a couple people in town like
see it
mary's yourself in their church yeah
with her yeah they're just there by
themselves and he like gives the rights
and then he does it
so which like i said doesn't seem all
that controversial to us but back then
it was like a big one martin luther did
that yeah was doing during the
protestant reformation that's what they
did
they married during the french
revolution they did that the [ __ ]
peasant revolutionaries would grab
priests and nuns and force them to marry
each other take that [ __ ] off and then
they'd kick them out of there get the
[ __ ] back into the hood
that's some funny [ __ ] doesn't the
[ __ ] french revolutionaries do that
they would force them to marry yeah they
were trying to absolve get rid of the
damn church
but yeah okay i'm sorry i didn't mean to
hijack it
been drinking yeah yeah that's a good
part of the movie though yeah well this
whole movie is good this is an amazing
[ __ ] movie i love this movie yeah uh
everybody's asking how they're gonna get
it get it you'll get it get it it's good
it's
it's like a history lesson but it's kind
of like excalibur but it's about the
church and it's [ __ ]
talks about the perversity of not only
just the church but just people in
general how [ __ ] corrupt they are
[ __ ] vying for power
killing innocent people and or making
one sin seem it's like it's huge when
they're even worse you know the person
yeah that's pretty much exactly what
happened
because honestly they don't give a [ __ ]
about grande they just want him out of
the way they just want that city so they
can tear the fortifications down in the
city and like root out all the
protestants and it's just like kind of
like they don't like him there because
he's a thorn in their side yeah and
like i said he's not helping his case
because he's a little bit of a
controversial figure beforehand
but
you know the little [ __ ] piddly [ __ ]
that he was doing is like nothing
compared to like what gets done to him
what they were doing but they were just
trying to get him out they were shooting
protestants [ __ ] dressed up like
[ __ ] black crows and [ __ ] for fun
yeah the king was yeah the king was
yeah because they captured a bunch of
cash again just shooting them in parties
and [ __ ] yeah he's like dressed up like
a black bird and then he's like shooting
him with a [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's
nice uh but yeah so of all the women
that are obsessed with this [ __ ]
uh the most obsessed is
the mother superior of the uh you know
convent yeah she's this pretty hunchback
yeah she's gorgeous but she's vanessa
redgrave yeah she's hunchback she has so
she comes out like that so her head's
like always crooked but she has like
this real like her spines all [ __ ] up
yeah
and uh yeah sister jean
and she is
a nut case
big time
uh so and she is totally totally her
like making out with him and stuff yeah
and she thinks she even knows him yeah
even though he's never remembered he's
never laid eyes on her before
um i think i should disconnect it hold
on oh it disconnected
huh that doesn't happen in a while okay
okay it's back that was weird somehow i
disconnected yeah that's weird yeah that
wasn't our cable up yup
that's on let me see what's going on
yeah what's going on
i'm losing my [ __ ] that hasn't happened
in a long time yeah
i don't know why it's doing that
i don't know if you guys can hear me but
it's going a little bit pear-shaped and
i don't know why because we have our
ethernet cable hooked up
maybe our connection is
oh well maybe it's back
okay tom went down to see what the deal
was with the uh with the router but it
looks like it's back now so
anyway
uh all right so where was i
so yeah so she's had all these elaborate
fantasies about him including like the
whole jesus fantasy him coming out to
cross them making out her washing his
feet with her hair blah blah blah
god doesn't want us talking about this
movie maybe that's what it is i kind of
did think something along those lines
for a second
it came it came back off we just kind of
lost it yeah
um yeah it was the service because we're
you know it's not wi-fi we're attached
uh high desert 004 says god doesn't want
us talking about this movie
making fun of him
[Laughter]
but yeah so like i said she's looney
tunes
uh so when she finds out
that he has married
she loses her
[ __ ] well because now prior to that she
had written because they lost their
confessor
and she was like oh i have an idea let's
she wrote a letter and she was like i
think that grande should be our
confessor so
he could be like at the convent all the
time and she could like make a move on
him or whatever
but he is not able to do it so they send
this other guy who looks like spock and
mignon yeah and because i remember
because i said oh like filet mignon
that's a that's his nickname filet
mignon uh but yeah so they sent him
instead and she's like super pissed off
yeah and this hunchback she's she's in
charge of like 30 nuns the young yeah
she's the mother superior she's like the
abbess or whatever they call they do
weird [ __ ] man they [ __ ] dress up as
men and women they dress up
they'll take a girl and dress her up
like like like [ __ ] like what's his
name for that minion they got me
grant grand meat grenier right is his
name grenier well now you know grande
grandia they'll dress a girl up like
grandier and then they'll pretend like
they're getting married and jumping in
the damn bed together and they're like
in the [ __ ]
you stop it
it's funny [ __ ] well like i said what
else have they got to do yeah because
they talk about they talk about having
sex with them and [ __ ] and they and they
might even die on each other jerking it
experience spying each other jerking it
over him and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] some
weird [ __ ] man yeah it's it's crazy yeah
uh so at this point like i said so she
starts losing her [ __ ] mind mignon
starts questioning her about it and he
decides hey maybe if we kind of like
hype this up a little bit he doesn't say
this outright but this is kind of how it
plays out maybe if we hype this up a
little bit we can say
that grandier is like possessing her in
the sense that like you know the witch
trials
where like where like a witch could like
possess somebody from afar like he's in
league with satan and he's possessing
her and giving her all these visions and
then it extends to oh he must be
possessing all the women like all the
nuns and actually how they do that
is they threaten they essentially
threaten to kill all the nuns
um they take them out in the woods and
like tie them all in a thing and they're
basically like aiming all their [ __ ]
arrows and [ __ ] at them and they're
basically like well um hey why don't you
just say that grande possessed all you
guys and they're just like oh yeah
absolutely so
then they can just go back to the
convent and that gives them license to
do whatever the [ __ ] they want so now
they're running around the [ __ ]
convent buck naked and like doing all
kind of crazy [ __ ] they're doing each
other they're [ __ ] having all kinds
of weird [ __ ] right well you gotta
understand it's understandable when
what they said in the early on is is
because some some chick
you find out who she is she tries to
join the convent well that's the guy
that that's the that's the guy that's
the girl that um that he ends up that's
madeline that's the one and the other
fear is like you and she's like why do
you think they're in here he's well
because they want to serve god and she's
like she's just laughing no they're in
here because nobody would wanted them
for marriage they were too ugly or that
or there was something wrong with him or
the family the family didn't have enough
money to put to put up a sizable dowry
and nobody married him so that so
basically these girls are in prison
they're all prisoners all the girls
seconds and irregulars yeah
so the the
the convey is a prison uh it's a prison
for women that couldn't be married off
yeah yeah and that's that's very true to
life yeah and it's a la and it's a lot
and and it's life
some of them girls are old yeah they're
in their 60s and 70s they're still in
there so it's not a happy existence so
they're just trying a lot of them didn't
choose it no so they're just trying to
get through
you know and
when the whole possession thing comes in
they're being encouraged to misbehave so
they just went but wild there was
[ __ ] having lesbian orgies and
[ __ ] putting their titties in dudes
faces put it in the king's face and the
king's like oh yeah he's loving it
so it was so they just
became hoes for god i mean they're
possessed so they can do whatever they
want they weren't being they weren't
being punished because that was the deal
they were trying to because they were
engaged oh sure it wasn't it wasn't
their fault
so um well because they bring in a witch
hunter yeah father bahrain
and he kind of whips everybody up into a
frenzy and then they do well they do
that one scene where um and i think this
was slightly cut out what's his name
father what bahrain bahrain now bar ray
is kind of like the ray manzarik
[ __ ] uh oh okay he does look very
much yeah if you're the the keyboard
player from the doors
pretty much exactly yeah yeah and he's
he does kind of have a rock star appeal
so they're trying to please him
uh and he's he's a psycho too he's you
know he's a good looking guy but he's a
[ __ ] psycho
and they're
putting down things up girls i was going
to say they're like giving people and
trying to get evil sweet like salty
boiling water whatever the [ __ ] they
were putting up in there
trying to see what comes out and analyze
it scientifically oh yeah you know this
is a semen here [ __ ] the devil's been
in here that kind of
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] it's yeah it's pretty
crazy but they was but that's true to
life but yeah that's that's what they
were doing [ __ ] that they would do yeah
they're like looking in their enema
thing and this stuff that was like they
were vomiting and everything and they're
like poking through there saying hey
that looks like some satanic even though
the highers out the higher ups didn't
believe it they're just like yeah yeah
whatever
it was just to keep the people happy so
they could get this [ __ ] job done
they knew what they were doing yeah and
it was all [ __ ] so essentially i
mean throughout most of this
uh when all the non-orgy [ __ ] is going
on and the enemas and whatnot yeah and
that was becoming a nightclub basically
the kids were showing up to see it and
people were partying in all this [ __ ]
chaos yeah because it was when i thought
it was hilarious it's not like a good
time yeah and all the rich people were
showing up in mass to watch it and be a
part of it yeah being like whoo yeah
right did you see her you know they're
laughing at the torture and [ __ ] [ __ ]
well yeah like i said they're they're
essentially like the you know yeah
the the mother superior you know uh
sister jean she's obviously not really a
sympathetic character but um because
she's looney tunes and it's kind of her
response you know
she's the one that kind of caused it
but
i mean she didn't deserve what they what
they did to her i mean they were
torturing her and for everyone's
amusement
pretty much yeah uh so yeah there was
that everybody just came and like looked
at it and ironically like while this
[ __ ] was going on
grande and his wife like weren't even in
town he had gone to
now he had gone to like talk to the king
right and he was like on his way back
because it was like you know a long
journey or whatever so he was on his way
back and he came back and like walks
into the [ __ ] convent or whatever and
he's just like what the [ __ ] is going on
in here it's like everybody there's like
hundreds of people and everybody's
running around like lunatics all naked
and [ __ ] and um you know so then
everybody like kind of like you've
possessed all these he's like what the
[ __ ] are you even talking about i wasn't
even here i didn't do this it's like i
never even met this [ __ ] chick yeah
you know the mother superior but
obviously like i said the powers that be
wanted him out of the way
so
they decide well they're to go ahead
with this big [ __ ] show trial even
though
most of them knew it was although like
some of the people seemed like true
believers like the witch hunter guy like
bahrain he seemed to really believe that
he was crazy though yeah he wasn't he
was crazy but most of you know the king
didn't really believe it richelieu
didn't really believe it they just
wanted him out of the way and it was
convenient yeah um that this had come up
and they're just like we're gonna like
pump up the outrage and you know the
blasphemy around this [ __ ] and we're
gonna blame him for everything they knew
knew how to use the system against their
enemies sure that's all it was yeah so
so just like in real life well he gets
tortured um you know they put the thing
like through his tongue and like they
they put him in that um but they called
that the extraordinary question right
where they put your legs in the in the
stock things and then they look like
beat this like broke um and [ __ ]
and they shaved him so it would be like
humiliating like they shaved off his
mustache and his hair so he was like
completely bald i think they shaved off
his eyebrows today desert oh four says
every actor in this movie gave a hundred
percent they totally did they totally
shoot up the [ __ ] scenery i mean like
i said you gotta
because this is a pretty outrageous
movie like i said it's
exaggerated but
reading the accounts of what really
happened it's not really that
exaggerated but i mean it's ken russell
so it's going to be exaggerated because
that was kind of his thing
but
you know the the commitment of the
actors
is just really
i don't know i just love how committed
everybody was to their [ __ ] role in
this they just gave their all
and that's amazing like i said i think
this might be my favorite performance of
oliver reeds he's just so like i said
even though he starts out as kind of
like a sleaze bag
um you know as the story goes on and
more and more forces are like marshalled
against him and like this horrible [ __ ]
like he starts getting tortured and all
this other stuff later on and he just
refuses to give in because he absolutely
knows why he's being targeted like this
and he just will not give them the
satisfaction of
confessing to possessing because he
thinks it's [ __ ] yeah that's one of
the angles of the movies you got a
flawed character who is not wholly
really by any s
even he is not
holy even by protestant standards okay
but he doesn't [ __ ] ever renounce his
faith he never gives up his faith in god
during all that [ __ ] and um never he
never [ __ ] uh confesses to the
[ __ ]
which he's a man to be admired for that
yeah like i said he ends up a hero even
he starts out as like kind of a little
bit of a sleaze like he's a lovable
sleaze but still kind of a sleeve he's
[ __ ] jesus he's bad but at the end of
the movie the principal he's like a
[ __ ] yeah he's he's almost like a
[ __ ] he's a martyr yeah to his faith
because he absolutely would not and even
when they were burning him a lot because
even the the executioner like says to
him i'll strangle you first
and um it turns out that bahrain the
witch hunter he's like [ __ ] that and he
just like you know started the fire
before the executioner could get in
there strangling the executioners were
trying to give him an easy out
if you confessed they would strangle you
first and then kill you and then bro
and then burn you burn you dead burn you
dead yeah they're not alive
but yeah the executioner was there it's
like look i'm gonna strangle you anyway
yeah yeah well because some people still
thought he was innocent yeah if well
according to the people in the damn
courts there was a [ __ ] couple almost
there a couple of revolutions revolts
that happened even in court most people
knew it was [ __ ]
well even mignon at the end
when he was looking at him across the
flames yeah he realized yeah that the
dude was probably innocent and he was
like oh [ __ ] and then he got sent to a
they said afterward he got sent to like
an asylum or whatever for saying that he
was innocent right so they were just
everybody that said he was innocent
innocent they locked him i was like oh
you must be crazy but you can see it in
his face he's like oh my god where's
we're burning
an innocent man and he felt bad about it
yeah and came out about it later but
yeah so even while he was burning to
death
he was like telling everybody you guys
are all [ __ ] the whole reason that
they're doing this was so they could
tear the walls down and take you soon
and take your city and now they're gonna
do it and that's exactly what happened
yeah like they came and knocked all the
[ __ ] walls down yep and he's like and
so he was trying to tell them like at
the end and uh that that's what happened
and like i said and then the final scene
which is in some versions is cut out
they actually bring the part of the
femur bone which you know not not too
inconveniently looks like a dildo uh
part of the femur bone which is all
charred and burned and they bring it
back to the mother superior and she
masturbates with it so that's nice
yeah
she caught she caused his [ __ ] death
yeah i mean
well she um she was crazy yeah and she
like i said she had never met him she
was just like uh talking about him she
was like a stalker from afar yeah and
they just used her to [ __ ] get him
yeah exactly so she was like a yeah she
ended up being a tool of them without
even really realizing it so she kind of
got abused too even though she was a
horrible person
but you know she probably had some
mental illness that they exploited it's
a great movie about patriotism
[ __ ] um
religion
the evils of religion and but also the
strengths of religion uh he never gave
up his faith in what he believed he
didn't believe in these rule based
[ __ ] though he was just he said it's
this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] from the heart
i married myself with that woman because
i loved her from my heart
yeah i don't need you all to [ __ ]
tell me yeah right and he's like i don't
see why that should be a problem
right so you know
so
he um he knew it was a [ __ ] up system
yeah he was a [ __ ] bag nobody's perfect
yeah so that's that's another lesson it
tells you in the movie
if you're waiting if you're looking for
somebody to look up to and respect but
but they have to be perfect in every way
that ain't going to happen nobody's
different in every way everyone is
flawed nope
now that goes back to these [ __ ]
crazy ass religions where
every character in the [ __ ] book
who's supposed to be a good person is
[ __ ]
totally perfect in every way you know
it's a mythology if it's like that it's
just that people aren't like that he was
a mixed bag
but he had principle they were bashing
his legs in with a [ __ ] hammer
and and doing and he would he would not
confirm he would absolutely not not
confess to possessing they were burning
him alive
and he would not they want him to
confess to possessing those women he
would not have possessed those women
nope
and he just would not and that happened
in real life too yeah that's what he did
in real life uh he actually he would not
give them the satisfaction yeah they
were like
if you confess we'll strangle you right
now and it'll be over with he's like
nope like [ __ ] you you're gonna have to
set my ass on fire all right i forgot i
didn't do that [ __ ] i mean can you
imagine can you imagine being that much
of a [ __ ] like i said
so he's like he's a great character
right and he was saying you know this is
because of god i love god because you
all aren't with god
yeah i mean basically he says right in
the in the show trial yeah yeah he's
basically like saying this whole [ __ ]
this is what's sacrilegious right here
you guys are like perverting right the
actual teachings of the church right
so he wasn't like oh the the beliefs are
[ __ ] he said what you guys are doing
is what you guys are doing is [ __ ]
and he's like and you're just doing this
to me so you can get
so you can get the city so you're
[ __ ] all of these people and people
in the audience uh agreed and tried to
revolt but the soldiers held them back
yeah and then you know they tried okay
let's go they moved on to the next they
tried to get it moving forward as
quickly as they could to get his ass
killed
it's as i'm saying i'm gonna stand my
ground this movie is awesome [ __ ]
epic flick like excalibur but it's a
different
historical time period it's got a
different
lesson to be
learned be right up there with my crazy
ass [ __ ] zardos which is from the
dude who [ __ ]
directed [ __ ] excalibur
about the future the present and the
future basically elites taking over the
world and depopulation and all that [ __ ]
and uh those three movies right there
man [ __ ] recently they've been good
real good
they made some cool movies back in the
past a lot of them kind of forgotten
this is what needs to be seen again it's
a trip it's crazy because i was watching
a review of this uh and this movie like
i said came out in 1971
and some of the people in the comments
who i guess were younger
oh we're we're skipping again why is
this happening i don't know we haven't
usually we haven't had that's happened
in a long time it's back um but yeah
it's got to be the service having a
problem well yeah that's what i was
telling you before yeah um
but
what was uh now i forgot what i was
saying because i got [ __ ] distracted
um
about what young kids were saying when
they saw oh and so so like some people
who were younger that hadn't seen it at
the time thought that the movie was more
recent they're like oh my god i can't
believe that was made in 1971. just
because the cinematography and [ __ ] like
that is so beautiful
i wanted to bring up too that even
though a lot is obviously this takes
place in the 1630s in france and some of
it was filmed that like castles and
whatnot but the set that they built
ken russell wanted it to look
modernistic it kind of does so he wanted
everything to be white yeah and he
wanted everything to be really angular
he said i want it to look kind of like
metropolis the fritz lang movie yeah
interesting in a prison the production
yeah the production designer on this was
derek jarman who actually went on to
quite you know great acclaim later on as
a director in his own right uh derek
jarman's blue probably his most famous
he also did a very you know big
acclaimed uh version of shakespeare's
the tempest he made a bunch of films a
big queer activist he died of aids i
believe and he also
worked a lot with
pumpkin post punk bands uh doing a lot
of their videos and music production and
stuff like that he worked with sex
pistols throbbing gristle uh the smiths
he did like a [ __ ] ton of stuff back in
the day and um you know and it's quite
it was quite well known in like in sort
of alternative or underground circles
but uh yeah so he was the one that did
the the set design that's the good they
look kind of like uh
kind of like prisons
very uh
uh
white tile bars yeah uh very
institutional
red crosses on things very real
totalitarian real kind of clean looking
the nun outfits look look awesome
they're kind of like kind of like gothic
the costume design this is impeccable
kind of gothic non-fetish looking stuff
there's sexual elements with some of the
stuff that they do it's
although it's it's not so much that it
takes you out of it and then like a lot
of the guys that a lot of the nobles
have some [ __ ] 1600s golfed out
outfits black and white and [ __ ] you
know big old spurs and
guts the soldiers have guns and [ __ ]
iron helmets and looks it's cool it
looks good from what i get determined
the costume design in this it looks very
over the top
but
it's not really that far off what people
really wore back then yeah this was the
baroque period
um so what for example like louis xiii
the king was wearing
that was pretty similar to probably what
he would have worn starts off with the
king cross dressing in the play yeah
he's dressed up as venus
yeah it's like the birth of venus with
versus clamshell and everything and the
cardinals watching it and he's like yeah
yeah it's a trip
the king was uh lou the 13th was looking
[ __ ] he was uh he was pansexual
yeah big time he's pansexual but i gotta
say i do love that scene where he comes
in in disguise like on his litter with
uh with all of his you know yeah all of
his posse yeah with the with the triage
the whole possibility with the with the
blood of jesus like in this thing going
like i brought something that'll that'll
get rid of all the demons and
everybody's like oh we're curing that
he's like right and up to this point
every time he's shown the king he seems
to be an idiot
but then in that scene you find out no
he's not an idiot he's trolling the [ __ ]
out of all you yeah
he doesn't give a [ __ ] it's just he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's just hedonistic
pleasure and having fun and killing
protestants he don't care he doesn't
even care there are protestants he'd
probably killed anybody
well yeah he's the king
he can do whatever you want he's the
king and he knows he's [ __ ] in charge
of this insane world and he's just gonna
[ __ ] all these chicks and do all this
[ __ ] pansexual [ __ ] until he dies
that he doesn't give a [ __ ] yeah that's
all it is he's not dumb he lets you know
absolutely not he
that whole thing there you find out oh
you're trolling because yeah i'm
trolling okay see you gotta go yeah
he even says have fun have fun and then
they take him away yeah and i was like
oh
[ __ ]
king knew all along he's funny
he knew those [ __ ]
he understood all this yeah
like i said he just didn't care he just
didn't care he didn't care that people
would get killed no that grande would
get killed or that the you know the
people in the city might get hurt or you
know that their city was going to be
like the fortifications taking down well
i guess he didn't want to put himself at
risk yeah so he just let it right yeah
yeah just when he's he's going to let
richarlison lay right yeah yeah i mean
long as he's partying he's happy just
let them do what they want that's what
it seems yeah it seemed more like he's
just kind of like yeah you guys the
little people will take care of yeah you
guys do i just want to have a good time
yeah party over here with all my money
yeah so you know
[Laughter]
anyway uh yeah juan says i don't think
that king liked chicks probably not uh
well he had women with him yeah he had
women with him i think he was just he
was everything yeah he was everything he
was into whatever
all right but uh yeah we ma'am we went
on for almost for more than an hour okay
yeah good
movies but like i said yeah this is a
classic i mean if you haven't seen it
especially if you're into like really
quote-unquote controversial stuff from
the 1970s like you know 120 days of
sodom or caligula or something like that
this is something that's kind of along
those lines
try to find an uncut version uh like
juan said you probably have to be a
bootleg there is a version on shutter
which is really nice it's all restored
and stuff but i'm pretty sure
uh that that one because you know
obviously the quote-unquote rape of
christ scene is not in there and the
bone masturbation scene is not in there
and i don't recall seeing any pubic hair
so i'm thinking this is probably like
the shorter us cut
some some of the stuff has been restored
in the uk cut but i think that the
completely uncut version you can only
get in a bootleg
so
i i would definitely try to seek that
out if you could find like a decent it's
free watch it even even the american
version we saw it's still worth watching
even if it's like watch it and then see
if you can find like the scenes that
were cut out they're pretty easy to find
yeah
they're around it's not gonna make a big
difference
yeah juan points out he told those boys
that women are disgusting that's right
he did didn't he okay yeah because
remember he had that little boy on the
litter with him and he was just like
some men like these women but they're so
like okay they're the ones that give
birth to men and that's so gross okay
yeah i remember he had a queen next to
him but i guess maybe he that she was
just window dressing i guess
see i thought well he had a little boy
on the litter like a kid nothing with
the girl in the wet red dress oh that
was the kid was that it was that a boy
now i can't remember now you're
confusing the hat on
next
one
uh
i don't remember okay i thought it was i
thought it was the queen
juan says there's a lot of pubes in the
uncut version okay yeah like i said i've
seen stills and like i've seen some of
the scenes that were cut out but i think
the virgin stone shutter doesn't have
any of that there's a lot of nudity
but they don't really linger on a lot of
and i think they took out there's one
scene where where they're doing like the
witch hunter in them or doing the enema
where they make it a lot more clear that
this is going up or butt
where i think in the shutter version it
was just kind of like implied like
obviously it's an enema thing and like
you know where that's going um and they
kind of imply it but i think it's more
obvious like in the uncut version that
that's where they're sticking it um but
yeah so uh all right so we've been going
on more than an hour uh go watch this
movie it's really good like i said it's
a classic especially if you're into ken
russell it's [ __ ] crazy and uh it's
pretty much i think it's probably his
best movie i don't know it's hard to say
because he's made a lot of really
awesome ones but uh yeah so i think
tonight
didn't tila recommend that we do mommy
dearest i think so we can watch it i
think we should do mommy dear so we'll
talk because she said about that like on
the show the other day and i noticed
that mommy dearest is free on pluto
and i actually love that movie so we're
going to watch that tonight and we will
talk about that tomorrow afternoon so
thanks everybody for dropping by and we
will see you guys tomorrow bye